The Great Wall of China was funded by a state
lottery.
Sylvester Stallone was so broke before his
script for Rocky was accepted that he sold
his dog for $25.
A few weeks later, he bought it back for $15,000.
In 2012, 146 girls in the US were named Khaleesi.
The first person to smoke in Europe was sent
to prison for being possessed by the devil.
India's Mars probe cost less than the movie
Gravity.
Fruits are the ovaries of plants.
In 1859, a panic swept America because young
people were playing too much chess.
The longest bout of hiccups lasted 67 years.
Elephants tickle each other.
Apple is worth more than Sweden, Poland and
Nigeria.
At 21, Mussolini was homeless and living under
a bridge in Switzerland.
At the 1956 Olympics, Russian rower Vyacheslav
Ivanov was so excited at winning gold that
he dropped his medal into the lake and it
was never found.
Before having their chests cut open and their
hearts pulled out, Aztec human-sacrifice victims
were given a cup of hot chocolate.
Prince Charles runs his Aston Martin on biofuel
made from wine.
All glossy magazines are radioactive.
Azodicarbonamide is a chemical compound that
makes things softer and bouncier.
It's used in flip-flops, yoga mats and McDonald's
Big Mac buns.